we are following the president's state
visit to London this morning Queen
Elizabeth is meeting President and mrs.
Trump at Buckingham Palace the first of
a series of ceremonial events the
president faces protests in London from
a slice of the British public and some
members of parliament who already are in
turmoil over brexit Roy Anika is a royal
correspondent for The Sunday Times of
London is with us from Buckingham Palace
royal we see movement there good morning
to you morning Roya
can you hear morning I can hear you can
you can you give us some idea what's
happening there yes so Donald Trump and
Melania have just arrived a short time
ago they will have had they've had a
welcomed by the Queen by the Prince of
Wales the Duchess of Cornwall the
president has been inspecting the honor
guard with the Prince of Wales and then
shortly after that has finished the
Queen will host a private lunch at
Buckingham Palace with the Prince of
Wales the Duchess of Cornwall the Duke
of Sussex Prince Harry will be joining
that lunch that's a the only involvement
he'll have in this state visit and then
after that lunch the Queen will take
Donald Trump and Melania through to the
picture gallery very famous part of the
the palace would beautiful masterpieces
on the walls to walk through a special
exhibition of items chosen from the
Royal Collection that reflect that
special relationship between the UK and
the US then after that Prince Andrew
will take the president and Melania the
first lady to Westminster Abbey for a
guided tour then he's going to have this
the couple will have that tea at
Clarence house with the Prince of Wales
and the Duchess of Cornwall back to
Wingfield house shortly and then of
course the big state banquet tonight at
Buckingham Palace right as we mentioned
earlier in the broadcast there's no love
lost between the Mayor of London Sadiq
Khan and President Trump but but I'm
wondering what the relationship between
Queen Elizabeth and the president is
like how do they feel about each other
well that is the question isn't it no
horn really knows she is the queen of
diplomacy of course they met last year
when President Trump came for that
working visit here briefly at Windsor
Castle and the Queen hosted him for tea
on that occasion of course
members of her family were notably
absent this time of course she's gonna
have much more support but you know
Donald Trump spoke very highly of the
Queen after that meeting you know he he
had wanted this visit he had wanted this
in a big state occasion the pomp and
pageantry of all the ceremonial stuff
that the Queen can offer he's getting
that I'm sure we're here some very warm
words both from the President and from
the Queen this evening at the state
banquets
look she's hosted some really
controversial figures over the years
Donald Trump's would be nothing compared
to some of the heads of state she's a
hat and she's hosted over the years
twelve US presidents she'll take it all
in her stride even when he goes off
script which I'm sure he world where
we're taking a look at pictures here of
some of that pop and circumstance
unfolding the president in the Queen
coming out making their first appearance
publicly the one of the questions I have
is Boris Johnson made me the new prime
minister and president Trump has broken
with tradition to weigh in on British
politics how's the public they're
reacting to his cannonball into their
affairs well I think we probably won't
really get much more of a sense of that
until this state visit
you know we're well into it probably
later today and tomorrow let's see what
he says in the speech tonight but it's
always an interesting call with US
presidents of course Obama came and made
those comments about the UK having to
think very carefully about leaving the
EU which is something that we know David
Cameron awesome to do and that backfired
so interventions by US presidents can
sometimes have the opposite effect of
course it is you know off script for him
to weigh in and say which candidate he
would rather be the next prime minister
we know that he's gone to Boris Johnson
that may that may help will that may
hinder Boris Johnson it remains to be
seen oh yeah have you heard anything
about protests against President Trump
we've already seen stories about that
very unflattering baby Trump that they
say is going to be activated what is the
mood of the British people about
President Trump coming to your country
well the great thing about the UK is
that you know people are free to to
protest peacefully and I'm sure we will
see some protesters out at some point
later on today and maybe even tomorrow
around Downing
because he holds talks with Teresa May
but look there is huge security around
this visit as well so it's much harder
people to get close to the palace things
are very cordoned off I suspect if there
are going to be major protests we will
see most of them taking place tomorrow
down around Parliament Square where they
were always huge mats protest but Donald
Trump he is a divisive figure here in
the UK we are rolling out the red carpet
for him not everybody agrees with that
they may self feel free to protest what
role will Prince William and Prince
Harry play in the ceremonies today do
you know yes so Prince Harry the Duke of
Sussex is coming to the private lunch
that the Queen is hosting at Buckingham
Palace shortly of course not with Megan
the Dutchess of Sussex who is still on
maternity leave she actually only had
her baby actually just a month ago
William and Kate will be at the state
banquet tonight where they'll join the
Queen and other members of the royal
family Harry won't be at that state
banquet but William and Kate will be
there with other members of the royal
family the Duke of York Prince of Wales
and the Duchess of Cornwall there was
there was some commotion in media for
the weekend about remarks President
Trump made about the Duchess of Sussex
which in full fairness were in response
to some of the things she'd said about
him in the past he used the word I
didn't know she was nasty in response to
that how much of a commotion has there
been in the UK about that yeah I mean
there's comments as you would imagine
have been widely covered these were
referring to remarks that the Dutch the
Sussex have made when she was Megan
Markel before she joined the royal
family when she had called Donald Trump
a divisive and misogynistic figure of
course
Nashes in the royal family you have to
be above politics she hasn't really been
saying anything about him at all but
these comments were brought his
attention in a series of interviews that
political editors did here with him and
it sounds like he wasn't aware of the
fact that she'd used these police terms
and so you know he made the comment that
he didn't realize she was quote-unquote
nasty that has been widely reported here
unlight
possibly from two slightly awkward women
between Donald Trump and Prince Harry
when he sees him later
but look the royal family had used to
all this controversy they'll take it in
their stride yeah and and we should
point out that the president also said
that I believe I'm not quoting exactly
but roughly he said I'm sure she's going
to be an excellent princess roni cthe
ank you very much